quoi
et le césar du meilleur acteur est
attribué à guillaume gallienne c'est le
quatrième césar de la soirée pour le
film il a débuté au cinéma 92 dans 3 blu
demeure de chant nemes parmi ses
principaux teams jet set roquefeuil
d'orchestre sagan musée haut musée bas
le concert et astérix obélix au service
de sa majesté
il est actuellement la fiche de notre
gros succès yves saint laurent jane
espère où il incarne pierre bergé et on
met on pourra le retrouver sur la scène
des comédies françaises ville incarnera
lucrèce borgia pardon ils doivent se
dire encore y'en a marre de voir sa
gueule à cela mais non merci extrêmement
ému mais mais avec les acteurs qui a
l'art je suis enfin bon je pense à mes
professeurs
je pense à mes professeurs les
avionneurs denis chekroun christian
crouzet jean pierre garnier raymond
acquaviva eric ruf daniel mesguich
dominique valadié stéphane braunschweig
françois florent oui bah oui mes
professeurs je leur dois beaucoup et
puis à des maîtres que j'ai eu la chance
de rencontrer soit juste humainement
soir dans le travail je pense à klaus
michael grüber et alain françon à qui je
dois énormément
et puis ma reine claude mathieu encore
toi mais je suis rentré aux français à
cause de toi
et puis et puis et puis je peux pas
recevoir ce prix sans sens le dédier à à
la troupe de la comédie française parce
que c'est grâce à ces grâce à eux que
que j'apprends à travailler plutôt bien
et surtout en m'amusant
mais en respectant en respectant surtout
l'esprit troupes
je sais pas pourquoi je prend l'accent
belge tout d'un conte m
c'est l'émotion mais mais voilà c'est
l'émotion qui fait ça mais voilà cet
esprit de troupe avec les partenaires il
en parlait le président est accusé
c'est vrai les partenaires et ça c'est à
la comédie-française que j'apprends ça
tous les jours
et donc depuis roland bertin catherine
samie qui s'était engagé pour être leur
fils est donc à eux et à tous les autres
que j'ai connu que je connais de puis
voilà donc à la troupe du français les
gars et les filles merci c'est grâce à
vous merci infiniment merci beaucoup
beaucoup